This next one's really gonna grind your gears, Drew,
are you ready for this?
Ooh.
This got me heated, everyone.
It comes from BuzzFeed.
So listen, a woman in a bridal party posted text
from her friend, who was the bride.
The bride wrote that she'd handpicked
all the bridesmaid dresses and quote,
they will all be a size eight,
so if you're not a size eight, I recommend hitting the gym.
(audience murmurs)
Yeah, the woman who posted this said,
she's a size 12 with no plans of being a size eight
by December, so she's quitting the bridal party,
thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
This got me going.
You know we're nice, I love people,
but lady, I don't like this.
Drew.
Show of hands, everybody,
who thinks that this is just unacceptable?
(audience hoots)
The people have spoken.
Yes, we have.
I couldn't believe this story.
I know, it's so rude, it's just ew, it's just ew, right?
But I do love the woman who said,
"You know what?
I'm so sorry, I don't need this."
I'm out.
(audience applauds)
No!
She is on the side
of self-respecting and right,
and I'm totally here for it.
Yes, and can I just say,
and I'm announcing this right now,
when I run for president, my platform is gonna be
that everyone in the bridal party
gets to pick their own dress.
Okay, all right, bridesmaids, you get to pick.
(audience applauds)
And I appreciate your vote, thank you.
I love it, I want you to be president.
(Ellen chuckles)
Okay, finally it's time for a pick
from Drew's little yellow book.
It feels weird to say my name.
(audience applauds)
These are actually vitamins that my dear friend,
Alicia Silverstone sent me.
They're her brand.
(audience applauds)
That's right.
It's mykind Oraganics Vitamins.
And I am totally hooked.
I take the multi-daily.
It's like this yummy, chewy raspberry flavor,
and it's got this great density.
I really like it.
And these are clean, plant-based vitamins
with no sugar or sweeteners added.
There you go.
And you've got all the greatest hits.
Every vitamin you could ever imagine she has.
Hit me with a gummy, I wanna try.
They're fantastic.
All right, what's this one?
And she has apple cider vinegar, turmeric,
Ooh.
vitamin D.
But I literally-
(audience laughs)
These are delicious.
I literally take her
They're great.
multi-vitamin every day.
And I will say that I, you know,
I treat my body a little bit like an amusement park.
Yeah, what, does everyone get a ride? (laughs)
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
I did have my fun back in the day,
but I've been single for six years.
Understood.
So, but thanks to Alicia,
I am like now taking my vitamins.
That's great, well, I understand why,
'cause these are so good.
(audience applauds)
They're so good.
I wanna share it.
So, I wanted to share
what has totally improve my quality of life with you guys,
and that's it.
(upbeat music)